no i'll have to ask for that now don't
ask for it it's very very painful but it
might like a little pain
a do not judge the lady in the leather
dress
and
can you see this you probably can't can
yeah it's tricky yeah because why it's
too thin it's like many of the actresses
that come out and say
they're
oh you're awesome in that movie about
vampires that don't actually suck blood
actually you know what
too good what this guy here i do no they
don't no don't that's a beloved american
if you keep sitting with your legs like
that i'm going to get you some tickets
to a broadway
show thank you
i can't move it because i'll crush the
sloth
right you're a is that is that a sex
thing crushing it
yeah all right you're you're a wh what
is he a gay robot scout yeah right i can
see he's caesar skeletons he's a robot
his name's jeff but what what have you
done this guy
can come over here and i'll show you
well my general issue is that i'm always
exhausted maybe it's because you know of
all the donuts
certainly processed sugar i bet you yeah
yes i'm addicted well you know whatever
you're doing i think you should keep
doing it though
i don't think you should be changing
stuff around i'll try not to no don't no
just keep feeding it
oh donut yeah yeah i know it's another
dollar do you ever do you talk to donuts
when you eat them i like my donuts so
fat their holes are closed
does that make me creepy i don't know
that's
gross really how do you like your donuts
then thin with a big hole
there's a giant camera and there's you
know our whole crew is sitting around us
and stuff like that and they're like
okay so just looking directly into the
camera which is a security camera
and just
just sex it up
because i'm trying to get this i do that
here every night
look at the camera in a second
[Music]
all right that's what i know i kind of
look a little bit kind of crazy i
understand but but just what you do is
you go like this you kind of must have
your hair and then play with your lips
oh go oh how long i've just been through
hair and makeup all right well you can
you can just go like this
sorry alex and then try to look like you
can't uh you can't remember what you
were thinking i i forgot or not
is that kind of i'm too sexy to remember
things
i'm hanging in there no i mean it's a
it's really well what are you doing i
mean what are you doing
do you do a lot
i do
just like that you do is that use that
machine
dory says dear craig i'm going to be
living in a house with four guys in a
few months any advice
stretch
i was like a prodigy nikita style can
you do all that can you do all that kind
of time
i can't
right but i can really pretend
i can pretend my ass off
don't do that pretend something else
some things
okay
some things you should just leave the
way they are you know what i'm saying
the heaviest food the hip well i don't
know that coconut's really a fruit it's
a coconut fruit i think a coconut is
it's a fruit i thought it was a nut it's
a fruit and a weapon no what and also it
can be a bra
if you cut it in half you make a fortune
getting the smaller ladies in belfast
[Music]
so what did you do when you got there
did you have any did you start acting
right away or did you have to get other
work
um no i had to wait my way around new
york and save money and wait tables did
you do that yeah i did that yeah that's
fun yeah it's a lot of fun that's a
great job isn't it
especially i noticed if you waiting
tables the swankier the restaurant the
more
sashimi eat there have you noticed that
yeah absolutely it's like wow yeah and
they don't tip either especially when
you yell at them well i have boo well
yeah but you know i have boobs so you do
i got i got i got some nice tips
i don't know
i don't know about you
right now
yeah no i'm just slowing things down for
the person that types out for the uh
for the audience who are hard of hearing
t-i-p-s
[Music]
nice
you know english is not my first
language either
not right now anyway ah oh i'm not going
i'm just you know i should go no i get
scared enough look like i got that [ __ ]
over there
i got skinny scares going on in my life
and then and then there's beth right
next to it
i see what i did
yeah
[Music]
god
have you been to france i haven't
i would like to have you yes many times
what do you do when you go uh enjoy the
cheese
a lot of cheese here we got wisconsin
yeah but
yeah but the difference is in france the
cheese varies from cheese to cheese for
example there's a piece of cheese and
it's called black
and then
there's a another type of cheese called
right
in wisconsin they go there's your cheese
you got your yellow cheese you got your
orange orange cheese
you got cheese cheese whatever you like
see now you're insulting americans
how dare you
how did you turn that around i
i've been doing this for a while
one more thing yeah like so you know how
you shave your own head right yeah all
right so have you ever like just like
shaved the whole thing
oh my god guys
you just did it you did it tonight is
that yeah like shave your entire body
there's this guy this guy's help here
they they asked me to ask you what yeah
they were like ask him before you come
out there like ask him if he saves his
whole body help me
ask him does he go completely or is it a
little airstrip what does he do yeah
yes
new york is such a great city to be yes
it is yeah did you ever do any modeling
by any chance
um
yeah yeah yeah did you do the runway
modeling you know oh right yes
i imagine you probably did yeah yeah
normally i can speak
not today having a bit of a hard time
this evening don't know what it is it's
kind of hot in this studio i'm feeling a
little
is it hot in here well you're wearing
that so um
i love your blue eyes i love everything
about you
i i know and and he's gay
yeah not anymore yeah
sure you know what it's the traveling
you're a pilot now yeah well i've been a
pilot for a while but i don't fly myself
well you can bet you're a bird i'm not
gonna go with you i'd say
[Applause]
no are you flying in the navy no you did
some flying no no no jews don't fly in
the navy
we just stand on the airport and say
here buy me a plane
no i i i was in i was yeah i was in
world war ii the big one i know you were
in ireland walking around going can i
get them
i've never even been here ireland i'm
not from ireland i've never been where
you from i'm from scotland that's better
yes it's better
[Music]
sit around all day long going all right
charlie pump it up
pumping your bagpipes get a day job for
granted
i'm an american no i'm not let me see
your papers i don't even know look i got
a tattoo i got to touch him i got a
tattoo right there don't i tattoo
sailors that shows like like you've got
a lot of class don't worry about the
tattoos you don't need the tattoos
you're a big star now hide the tattoo
the navy when a guy had a tattoo it's
supposed to be tough you're not tough i
met your backstage you know you
you're a nice guy with a lot of class
you know and you got a wonderful by the
way i saw your baby yeah yeah my
six-month-old baby just has a wonderful
baby and the kids like this
no it's adorable you know what's amazing
though i mean i mean this with a great
deal of respect he looks exactly like
you right now
[Music]
welcome back my first guest tonight is a
fantastic actor the best actor in the
world
how dare you laugh he actually is
the best actor in the world
thank you okay
well don't wait wait i have to finish
off telling them the film you're in
go on then
he's in a film it's the best film in the
world the best man in the world
i love you i love you too
is it better than films that have liam
neeson in them
no films are better than once exactly so
you have harmonicas yeah do you blow the
mouth organ i
i do you blow the mouth morgan
how do you think i got this job
do you want to do the awkward pause now
i mean it is about time no no let's not
do the awkward you don't want to do the
awkward pass
it's so awkward
what do you want to do then i want to
feel comfortable
yeah come over here then
you haven't been to scotland or i've
been to scotland i went to isle of skye
oh that's very close yeah oh my gosh
it's like it's so beautiful there yes it
is yeah i ca every time i think about it
that's true and we were i know oh my
gosh well i was there during summer too
so
goes on all night long
british bike yeah right but also no
norton commander not in commando but
also i've also had some american iron
but do you still ride yeah well a little
bit i know since my last accident kind
of like knocked the window at my sails a
little bit what happened to you yeah i
was on one of them v rods and i tried to
go around a corner
were you at a high rate of speed what's
the point of being on a bike yeah
yeah i'm going to have this
it's a coconut thank you
have you have you got a no are you gonna
get a lovely bunch of them no
[Music]
this is it i don't you're not gonna cut
it open and put a straw in for me um
well i don't have anything well you know
what i do actually there's a knife here
and a cutting board but i don't think
that knife will cut there let's see
let's have a go give it a bash let's see
nice
oh no
there you go
yeah
it's a coconut don't be ridiculous
come on if only i had little spindly
fingers yes
[Laughter]
there you go all right come on then
wait can i just stop you what what i got
my fingers caught in the damn
do you want a drink of coconut juice no
i feel like i want a banana now you want
a banana no you're gonna have a banana
i just no you're gonna have a dance
look at that now i've seen it i just
think i just rather have a banana if
that's okay
do you mind
thank you small banana large banana
large banana i thought so lucy punch
everybody we'll be right back with
this
uh really often i often i dream about
the end of the world
that's a sex dream
so what about when i dream about sex
that's a sex stream
okay so what about
uh
sex dream yeah of course
i'm a freudian you see the freudians
believe that everything was real well
freud believed it was all about sex
whereas the youngins were like oh no
it's about unicorns and stuff
how are you look great thank you very
much how long have you been married now
already on that yeah
just trying to keep up on it see how
it's going uh let's see it's been
november december january almost four
months okay that's the tricky period
yeah it's it's starting to get rocky you
know come on now you have a nice
valentine's day first valentine's day
married um yeah i i kind of dropped the
ball craig
[Music]
i don't think anyone would mind
just pick it up keep going
[Music]
can i just look at this what is this
it's a tattoo has everybody seen it but
me uh no never did they all know about
it are you allowed to show it yeah i was
just so intrigued i stopped going it
goes it goes all the way up there
[Applause]
goes down loops down your leg
around you just keep going i'll tell you
when you hit the right
do you know what i wish other late night
talk show hosts that weren't working
today because memorial day would phone
me or something
[Applause]
let's see if i get that glittery ball
you know it looks pretty good there's a
good deal and it's not bad
17.99 yeah they're throwing the tape for
free i was studio 54.
looks like jay leno is a flying
[Applause]
i'll be back in eight months
can never get rid of him can you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]